yeah yar yar a peewit bum bum I be with
Jack Oh Boober duper I be with Lord
Mannion I lost me leg to a great whale
old hair beard and stumpy leg the
deadliest pirates this side of the
Mississippi yarr matey serious question
serious question
real pirate talk howdy pirates laughs
that's gonna be a bit of a problem for
me I'd be a bit thick in the dome
pirates a dome right the ladies they
call the old mushroom cap don't know if
I told you you should move with that
ladies but upon the cast is that a
pirate fun odd cast it's called the
fungus among us boner
we're takin our boner cast we're
trademark sometime in the future be how
did you slimy dogs not be a very
complicated map for me brain
one of these scallywags literally jumped
right on my ass was it a man with a
fierce face or a man with a butcher it
were a diaper baby we be pirates wait
tis every man for himself Nicole Wade
Wow whoa wait a real time real talk
why did that [ __ ] me laddie for realsies
in serious the whole gay thing is not
really cool with pirates
you know we're all dudes on this ship
pink one eight Willy lost both legs but
I'm okay with it I don't know did you
take your peg leg and I don't all go
explore in the seven holes I'd be okay
with that
yeah trust me trust me mateys
I'd be alright with the gay thing too
but you know it's it's like a it's an
image thing right and you can't you
can't be the pirate who's like the gay
one because then you'd be like me or you
know someone from hookers if you want to
take your harpoon and search me blowhole
that'll be fine Tereus leader you walked
right past me oh gosh darn it all this
talk about PC culture got me thinking
about other things perhaps this video to
be needed a trigger warning probably are
we'll put a cannon warning at the
beginning of it one warning is that code
like warning landlubbers Tannen episode
but wells are dicks I kind of yard the
boner cast might have had it
it's gonna be like this then is it guess
what I be now putting me in your mouth
turn your mic up then stop being a
scurvy bastard wait doesn't understand
how pirates really are great gravy
there's a bird's nest fellers fellers I
think you'd be talking to me cruise
mystic bird is or is not a crow a bird
before you jump all over my [ __ ]
just tell me a cruelty I'm not saying a
crowing a bird but all birds ain't
clothes if you know what I so just to be
clear though my discussion was less
specific and therefore I'm Gilbert
Godfried
you know for the guy that was like I'm
cool with it
I'm down with the other team Wow oh my
god there's so many levels
oh my god I'm a pirate I'm Christopher
Walken as Captain Hook Wow captain
fondest rocks from stroke 19 days a
stroke stroke this nice good a bit large
I'm stuck I need pirate assistance okay
most noble of ye now I'm a level above
you wave react will get your
up higher okay closer to your face level
above me you say is that better are you
they said they were on a boat wink wink
I suppose that means they might be over
oh never mind I was wrong well okay sure
be other boats everyone just needs to
relax with me lady ah
good shot there I did US Navy Jones no
give up your comrade Bob your service
pales in comparison with your bucket
frame that was I can't believe this
utter [ __ ] that's not you can't
believe this not a [ __ ] like what
are you talking about there's no time
for a grandma to be interjecting entire
it matters to the pirate home aren't you
serious wait are you taking the piss are
you I maybe you should stop talking wait
this might be dropping frames like a
[ __ ] whale these are made for walkin
her that
we don't need an audience for this one
just put me out of my misery and then
move on with your life
the regrettable decisions that I be
making in my life or mine in mine alone
you just move on I'm sliding another
boat in and out of me booty
mark take me to the Stars I'll try but
old boat beers been seeing better years
than this I don't think I'm ship worthy
take me for a ride you dog ah I can't
move
dude you're cops wobble flip that's not
the cops wobble flip they got me this
isn't for me
he's with the ocean no what could you
say turns English for battered Jack be
off jack off B now Jack be gone
you knew what you're saying the moment
you left your mouth
nobody says boots and [ __ ] [ __ ] one
more time I'm gonna have to get very
angry what what what are we supposed to
have said am I an [ __ ] BAE baebae
hearings gone from all these cannons oh
I I I saw that Jackie boy yeah I I not
believe that work that works very much
the booty bass how did you jump off the
side of the boat did you then we go
right there pirate friend I will sing in
the only shanty I know that be enough
I'm okay there's homosexuality briefly
it's a welcome change I'm okay with
diggie yeah that'd be the children of
the day pirates alliance future job
don't forget to edit this out the GPA
indeed it's a respectable organization
so it be so it be
yeah Wow right yar yar I really found I
really found wow I really found the
crappiest place I could huh I really
went right for it and describe it for me
it's crappy and ah I were going to help
you now I shall not oh wow
wait what even the [ __ ] REE wait wait
don't don't do that you really got it
made just chill out yar are we near by
not even at that's not what I was
wanting to hear are you a nerd don't
know that were not a clue that were just
a large oak are you totally UK he smokes
he's certain not a bottle there's not
there's not another one like him on the
boat that be sure perhaps later pirate
Bob it sounds like your accents going
there he be he be unique it's what I
summarized what have ye be near him
methinks he be in this very room seems
he be a boss cuz this one be underground
look wider be a cactus on this your ship
our cadet but the marketing move yeah
yeah when when it comes out you but you
know ye in trouble we already in trouble
you're really in trouble because it's a
cactus is the thing it's it's not like a
cracking sort of thing it's just just
the cactus stuff my computer telling me
it be riester no postpone that I really
I really be already losing my voice
let's just talk pirate arrr yar boy mate
I be I be on the ship are vast I'd be on
the ship where's the table I be
searching for these land just relays
talking pirate normally it's just
christopher walken that's how we got is
matey be be be the cool reference a hint
or would you like a sip of grog the beer
Mageia cannon cipro cannon good haps not
perhaps perhaps not try one more time
you're in and be the wrong ability to
understand is good Bob Oh III ignore hi
rare I never got to go to school oh shut
up you're about to become a lawyer yeah
that were kind of a mistake if I'm
honest it'd be a hard life then you go
up in the lawyer stand and please talk
like that
why yes mister be in the chair there he
Honor may I approach the witness easy
innocent I say I have some queries for
him queries be right up to the Markab
Your Honor at this time
defense moves defense exhibit number six
into evidence
real lawyer have you have ye any
objections that actually is legit lawyer
talk yeah oh all the lawyers washing
where anywhere it was a target that's
that's the thing you say to move
something into evidence once you've laid
the foundation right oh sorry Bob I know
you were there Thanks close the door
behind one of them be elevated oh oh I
might be able to see I don't know where
opps well bingo where his name oh that's
a no oh no oh the bird's nest oh you
think that do ye you you'd be entirely
corrected Jack be saying you up there
and mark me down below which means Jack
use your in your channel timed out oh I
thought we disabled that our God his
computer it didn't I will admit you've
both walked by me multiple times I
thought I just certain shorter to know I
just sharted how 30 my dancer I are on
the poop deck so your shirt includes not
to be too far away outside yes me do be
outside yes well by process of
elimination you seem to have almost
deduced the clue
it was only after the 19th bottle get
murdered vegetable you kidding me from
the tea sipping sissies from across the
pond